[Music]
what is rpm cross-platform solutions
where you write this for multiple
platform so you can write this for
Android Windows and iOS this one
dependency on mobile devices it supports
multiple languages it allows execution
on natural devices in simulators
philosophy for Appian this what you
release any language any chamber
standard a there and open search so you
can see that this is what I have
mentioned to you as well
appium uses vendor provided automation
framework this requires local violation
of the application this means you are
testing exactly the same application
without any changes for these days
corporations who are so what happens is
aptiom interacts with the UI Automator
by Google
it interacts with the XE test by Apple
it interacts with the window app driver
from Microsoft and that's how it can
automate all three platforms in one go
happy amuses selenium webdriver API is
for all the plane modes appium webdriver
bottle client server protocol that is
JSON wire protocol protocol makisi one
can use any this you write your test
cases what client libraries are
available one can use any unit testing
framework so if you want less jgj in it
or anything like that you can go ahead
and use it a PM extends to apply one and
provides additional eight a specific to
the moma test automation so of course
that's a well it's the you know step
here that's valid point but when you use
app your many use app in life ready it
gives you some added classes added
methods which is special to the mobile
automation that is why because in mobile
to do swiping tap because in mobile to
do tapping so there are many things
which are specific to the mobile apps
which is being provided by a PM library
selenium webdriver is widely adopted in
the market for test automation and this
reduce a learning curve protesters
because you know selenium webdriver now
you can easily switch to RPM because
there is not much with what you need to
learn the grammar is also w3 standard
RPM is an open source framework which is
the best part there is a large community
contributing to its enhancements
absolutely so even if you face any
issues you will get an answer easily
from anyone from the community you know
there is a very big community of this
appian there is a good support from
vendors as well Apple Microsoft and
Google of course you know they will
always keep their automation who is
up-to-date and set somewhere
healthy old itself
reading because google google launches
their new feeding system they will
nature that their tool which is used for
the automation on for the testing
purpose it works perfectly fine with the
new operating system so you know the
dependency that as soon as like here in
selenium we will always have to see we
will always have to make sure that our
selenium libraries are up-to-date with
the Firefox version you know with the
checker drivers and all those stuffs not
here everything is on Google if they are
launched in your browser they should
have their or omission views updated so
there is a good support for measures how
the appium box like I mentioned here so
appium access server that implements the
drivers RPM is a server here it is
written in known GS
this is scripts where are executed by
sending HTTP requests with a pin server
using json wire protocol so here
somewhere or the other they are using
selenium grid somewhere or other they
are using traces of selenium 3 because
what will happen or if I'd not see it as
lynnium drain and if you have heart of
selenium RC remote control this is how
what the philosophy they are following
action because your script sends the
commands you have your server which
converts that command which is
acceptable by the home devices and this
is what your remote control server used
to do earlier you know but results are
sent back to client whose execution
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos Turner DUP and get certified
click here